Our second guest is Tina Eliassi-Rad, a computer science professor
at Rutger's University.
She studies data mining and machine learning with a special emphasis
on the data that comes up in network science.
There's been an explosion in interest in studying networks and network science.
If you could comment a little bit about where Big Data is coming from.
[Tina Eliassi-Rad, Associate Professers, Rutgers University] Big Data is being generated by us.
We go on Twitter and we tweet away.
We go on Facebook, and we post photos and we post status updates.
That's actually where a lot of the Big Data nowadays is coming from.
Also, the other aspects, if you think about healthcare--
all the MRI imaging and all these other kinds of tasks that now are done with computers,
that's where Big Data is coming from.
In particular, because the idea is that if you analyze the data,
that data will tell you something about your customers
and then you can better serve your customers and then your profits will go higher.